so donald trump is very worried about
the attention that the
uh the dnc the democratic national
convention is going to get
this week and one of the things they're
doing is having campaign advisors
kind of manage expectations their trump
campaign advisors are floating the idea
that joe biden might get an 8 to 10
point
bump this week from the dnc now that's
extremely unlikely but the idea is
if they say biden could get 8 to 10
when biden gets three or four which is
typical from a convention
they can say oh no biden underperformed
nobody
likes him we expected him to get eight
to ten points but he only got three or
four so they're doing that
trump's flying to multiple cities this
week to do rally-like events which we'll
be covering
separately so i won't spend a ton of
time on that right now
and in addition to this donald trump is
also doing a bunch of interviews he's
doing a bunch of press and he started
off the week on fox and friends again
and it went really badly before we start
with the politics i want to start with
the strangest moment
donald trump's younger brother robert
trump tragically passed away over the
weekend in his
early 70s trump of course struggles to
show any emotion or human connection
asked about it he's trump says they
say robert was my best friend which is
really
weird language to use about your
supposed best friend and brother
take a look at this bizarre video hey
listen
uh you know a lot of people have been
thinking about you and your family
over the weekend i knew you were able to
get to the hospital before your brother
robert died here in new york city we are
so sorry
for your loss well i appreciate it it
was not
not a great weekend it's very hard you
knew it was going to happen but still
when it happens it's a very tough thing
he was a great guy he was a tremendous
guy you know
he was my friend i i guess they say best
friend and that's true
and uh you know losing him
not easy that is really really strange
language
i guess they say he was my best friend
and that's that's i guess that's true
what i think is that the statement that
was put out by the white house quoting
trump saying he was my best friend
trump didn't really write it and trump
didn't really say it
so when trump says they say he was my
best friend he really means
the people who wrote the statement
attributing that quote to me
they said he was my best friend and i
guess he sort of was
and then lastly trump is asked again
about his late brother robert trump
and trump's sort of eulogy was about
trump wasn't robert trump wasn't jealous
of my success
and he thought i was a great president
like it's all about trump if you can
believe that
most loyal people there was no jealous
you know a lot of times in
families i hate to say it but there's
jealousy and
especially among children and among
children that are competitive children
there's because he was very competitive
there was not an ounce of jealousy he'd
go around talking about
how great this is for the country and
it's so incredible and
and he was my biggest fan people were
telling me all the time i spoke to your
brother and your brother was
was so thrilled and and so thrilled at
what was happening
and what was happening for the country
was he was so angry with china
because of what happened where the
plague came in and they shouldn't have
allowed it to happen they could have
stopped it he was so upset by that
it was he couldn't more than people
would be upset a lot of people have
already forgotten
and you can't forget but he was a
fantastic guy
well we're very sorry for your loss and
um well thanks
asked about his brother who died two
days earlier
trump says he was loyal to me he wasn't
jealous of all of my great success
he was mad at china because of the
plague and he thought i was doing a
great job
this is not a person with normal emotion
or with normal
emotional connections to others so
that's out of the way
let's now get into the political stuff
trump again just insisting everything's
fine with the virus
and says without his border wall which
mexico was going to pay for but didn't
uh and which he was going to build
across the entire u.s mexico border
but didn't he says without that border
wall
things would be much worse which is
ridiculous take a look border wall but
can i ask you something about new york
then you shouldn't let it be in office
because we would have right now
the plague coming in like you know those
280 miles i built have stopped
like hundreds of thousands of people
mexico is
heavy heavy covered territory they're
highly infected
i built the wall and that wall to stop
people from coming in
if she said that and i know sleepy joe
said it he said
uh we should stop the wall and i might
even tear down the way he wants to tear
down a wall that's
the best border wall ever built in terms
of the success of it so you really hear
that
manic energy from trump shot out of a
cannon as i say
and to add some facts to this trump says
if it weren't for his 280 miles of wall
which is like nothing by the way we
would have hundreds of thousands of
additional cases coming in from mexico
the numbers just don't bear this out
number one in total cases mexico
has 10 percent of the cases that we do
now mexico has fewer people that's true
so per capita the u.s is eighth
in cases and mexico is 57th that's per
capita
now that can depend on testing well in
the u.s
we are 10th in deaths per capita mexico
is 13th in deaths per capita so it's a
complete
fantasy world fox and friends allows it
completely uncritically then trump
starts to insist
that the world is calling him because
he's so good at dealing with turkish
president erdogan nobody knows how to
deal with erdogan other than trump
trump tuning his own horn here take a
look hold me up they need help with
turkey
the heads of countries last week they
called me up could you call her to one i
said
why he's you're the only one that he'll
listen to he doesn't listen to us you're
the only one i said
is that because of the united states he
says no that's because of you
that's because of your personality
you're the only one that he
will listen to what about you know what
i don't like saying this publicly but it
happens to be true
i get along with him and he listens and
is this maybe the most narcissistic
thing that we've heard donald trump say
then then trump compares the taliban
to the hosts of fox and friends
interviewing him in this interview this
is weird
reconstituting in afghanistan though and
you couldn't if you look at her issues
you couldn't be more difficult i'll take
them out brian if they're reconstituting
i'll take
them out but we had we had at one point
a hundred
more than a hundred thousand soldiers
that's ridiculous
and we're ready to do whatever we have
to do we're dealing with the taliban
i said look let me tell you something
and i've dealt with them directly
these are tough people they're like you
people maybe not that tough
but you know what these are tough people
i said look if you play games
we're going to come and we're going to
hit you a little harder than any country
in the history of the world has ever
been hit
i guess maybe for trump this counts as
adopting a sense of humor i i don't even
know what's going on
uh trump continues to be unable to
pronounce kamala harris's name correctly
now that may not change
while he continues to allude to the joe
biden dementia stuff he still can't say
kamala's name
maybe people are going to feel sorry for
him and maybe he wouldn't but our
country is too important for that
you're dealing with people that are very
sharp you're dealing with world
class chess players in the leaders of
these countries i know them all
we do very well with all of them erdogan
of turkey
uh all of them you can't have a guy
that's shot you can't have a guy
that doesn't know where he is you can't
have a guy that's afraid to leave his
basement because
he can't speak any longer and by the way
in his best day he wasn't good you know
that
he was not the guy but but we're not
talking about a bad time
and you can't do that you can't feel
sorry for him and vote for him and
because if that means then the kamala
harris's are going to take over she's a
disaster
look at her positions on everything
kamala of course is a fictional drug
in the series battlestar galactica joe
biden's
running mate is kamala kamala harris
then trump is asked about people
claiming that he might not leave
office if he loses in november and
what's amazing about this is
trump doesn't deny it he's asked well
what about the people saying you're not
going to leave in november
he just bashes hillary hillary's not
even the person he's running against
this time around
mr president your reaction well the
first thing i think of is crooked
hillary clinton when during one of the
debates she
asked whether or not i would leave
office would i accept the results of the
election do you remember would you
accept
the result and i gave her a decent
answer and
the problem is she didn't accept it she
went crazy she's still going
crazy i mean she's gotten nuts and so so
have they i mean
they call it trump derangement syndrome
i don't know if that's true or not
but it's certainly close i go by the
election now with that being said i have
to tell you
that if you go with this universal melon
where you send
millions of votes in california tens of
millions of ballots
being sent to everybody and their dogs
okay dogs are getting them okay
not exactly inspiring confidence that
donald trump will leave peacefully again
i believe he will leave
but i believe he will do it if he loses
by claiming it was rigged
possibly catalyzing and coalescing his
supporters to real world violence
out in the streets i think it could get
very very ugly
and we need to be prepared for that as
much as we need to be prepared for the
voter suppression
and everything else that is going on
case in point
the post office now says there are tens
of millions of ballots at risk
and that's what i want to talk about
next if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video